this is called quadratic identities now
we've encountered this idea of
identities before and to prompt your
memory I've put this up on the board
right or these rather these are
identities
they're not just equations they're not
less than equations what makes these
identities and not just equations they
are true they are always true no matter
what values of X you put in there these
things will be the case as opposed to
say something like this that equation is
sometimes true if you put in a specific
value of x that will be true but if you
put in any value of x here that you like
it works and that's what we call an
identity okay
strictly speaking therefore I really
should put in OOP
some extra lines in there because just
like it is like congruence means these
aren't just you know similar to each
other these are exactly the same shape
just you're looking at them differently
these are exactly the same thing you're
just looking at them differently okay
now it's the same deal with the
quadratic identities and we look at
identities in quadratics for the same
reason that we look at quadratics sorry
we look at identities in trigonometry
sometimes a particular way of looking at
something makes it much easier to deal
with that the other or vice versa
and so you want to reframe the question
you want to rephrase it because you can
solve it this when it looks like this
and you can't solve it when it looks
like that okay and I'll give you an
example shortly here is a pretty typical
kind of question that you could have a
look at or might be presented with under
this heading and I want you to now pick
up your pen and write these two
expressions down now the question is
express this quadratic here in the form
of this express the first line in the
form of the second that's what the
question is so what they are implying is
that I can say that this is identical to
this
supposing I know what a B and C are
equal to okay so I can say 2x squared
plus 3x take away 6 is exactly identical
to
this second expression for every single
value of x that exists so long as I know
what a B and C are and there's only a
specific a B and C for which this works
okay so I'm going to show you two ways
of doing this you already based on what
we've looked at this morning and in
other topics you already know one of the
methods or at least how like the
principle underneath one of the methods
what could you do to have a go at
finding what a B and C are any
suggestions take back to what we did
just this morning if I expand out right
over on the right hand side I've got a
whole bunch of manipulation to do but
presumably I will end up with a
quadratic in X and there's a quadratic
in x over here so I should be able to do
a comparison of what again coefficients
and then I set them to be equal then I
can find a B and C and that will work
let's give this a go and see what
happens on the right hand side
oh yeah question so there's a there's a
bunch of different ways to work this out
as it happens I don't believe C is
negative 6 but I'll show you that in a
second ok in fact you just reminded me
there's not two ways to do this well not
only two is there's at least three we'll
see if we get to all of them by the end
of this I'm definitely gonna show you
two let's say Paul suggestion to begin
with and expand this guy right so on the
right hand side this is going to be x
squared plus 2x plus 1 yep plus BX plus
B plus C how's that look is that okay I
can keep on going so I'll expand this
whole thing here ax squared + 2 ax plus
a and at this point I've expanded as far
as I possibly can
so now it's time to begin comparing I've
got some x squared terms on the left and
I've got some x squared terms on the
right let's carefully look through all
the terms and see how many on the Left
how many X Squared's do I have
I've got two of them there's one turn
but how many X Squared's are there well
there's two well you have a look at the
right-hand side how many terms have x
squared in them just the one term and
there's the a right there so you can see
comparison of coefficients for the X
Squared's is quite nice and simple right
that's good let's keep going down the
line what's what's the number of X's on
the left three this one's a little more
complicated not heaps but a little more
because you can see I have an X term
here and an X term there do you agree so
these guys here should make up three and
then lastly have a look at the constant
terms so with no X's here you've got a
negative six have a look on the right
what's left behind a plus B plus C there
you go
so now I can do my comparison and I'm
going to mention like I went through
this in a particular order the order in
which you compare them will make things
easier or harder so I'm going to say by
comparison
I can just say equals to done no need to
go and make a make a drama about it if
you want to be really technical or nice
you can say where I get that from is the
x squared coefficients yeah what about
the X coefficients what do I write from
there I would say that to a plus B is
equal to three but I already I just
worked out what a was so I might as well
just work this out now write a is two so
I can say four plus B equals three so
now I know what B is okay I've done the
X Squared's I've done the X's the last
one is there it's the constant term
okay so let's have a look on the right
hand side as the dimension I've got a
plus B plus C what's it equal to on the
left near six but I know what a and B
are equal to already two and negative
one yes so it looks to me like this
would be one I subtract from both sides
which gives me that happy so excuse me
there was method one
I now have values for a B and C so if I
wanted to I could say right up the top
that this is equal to let's see here -
lots of this and take away one lot of
this and subtract that they go sorry
Jeff question or why are all my minus
signs different okay so I found a B and
C I have answered the question because a
B and C were not the answers we wanted
to write this in a new form so this new
form is the answer okay
by the way we wouldn't say that this is
a quadratic in X we'd call this guy a
quadratic in X plus one or if you had
like something different here I could
have a quadratic in Y or a quadratic in
sign or a quadratic in whatever you like
okay all right happy times does that
make sense
by comparison of coefficients that's
method one okay maybe I'll even write
that about here is where I start doing
it because the key thing is that it
requires expansion okay